[Music]
cartoons are still one of the most
popular forms of TV entertainment going
the use of animation captures the
imagination of people both young and old
and sometimes classic series are brought
up to date and made even better than the
originals be sure to watch to the end to
see how the Powerpuff Girls has been
improved for a new generation if this is
your first time visiting our channel
then make sure you give this video a
thumbs up and subscribe here are 5
cartoon reboots that are way better than
the original 5 duck tales for those of
us who grew up in the 1980s duck tales
was a major part of our childhoods the
story of donald duck's nephews Huey
Dewey and Louie and his billionaire
Scottish uncle scrooge mcduck was the
very first time that the legendary
Disney studio had made a cartoon that
had been syndicated a total of 100
episodes were made over four series the
show was a massive hit spawning the
spin-off movie and a classic video game
so when news came out that the show was
in line for a remake starting in August
2017 Disney fans held their breath and
hoped that it would live up to the
original but guess what Disney isn't a
studio known for letting that stands
down and the new duck tales was even
more than the show's biggest supporters
could have ever hoped for showrunners
nat yung berg and francisco and gone a
had grown up with the original cartoon
and wanted to bring it back for a new
audience
they rerecorded the legendary theme song
with singer-songwriter felicia barton
and hired a star-studded voice cast top
of the bill with scottish actor and
former doctor who star David Tennant who
lent his talents to voice Scrooge we
loved the original but we think that the
new duck tales which has received rave
reviews blows it out of the water for My
Little Pony Friendship is Magic back in
the day my little pony was the number
one kids TV show for literally millions
of children all across the world the
story of a group of magical horses wild
youngsters and made a pretty penny for
franchise originator Hasbro - so when it
was announced in 2010 that both the toys
and the cartoon were due for a reboots
people didn't know what would happen we
think the biggest surprise was that my
little
so often seen as a thing for girls would
attract a range of male fans known as
bronies these young and not so young men
helped blow apart gender stereotypes
let's be honest people who remember the
original phenomenon had absolutely no
idea that this was going to happen but
the show's main themes of working
together using kindness to defeat evil
and the power of friendship reached out
to a whole new audience it didn't
exactly hurt matters that the new show
entitled My Little Pony Friendship is
Magic had a radically new animation
style either gone were the soft gentle
cartoons of the 1980s they were replaced
with hard edged comic-book style
psychedelic artwork these coupled with
an increase in humor and excitement
meant that the new show was able to
absolutely knock the socks off the
original that said we'll always have a
soft spot for the first series three
scooby-doo mystery Incorporated
scooby-doo where are you is one of the
best-loved and most iconic TV cartoons
of all time the stories of teenagers
Fred Velma Daphne Shaggy and their Great
Dane
scooby-doo were smash hits across the
globe it was yet another classic cartoon
from hanna-barbera and did let a whole
lot of spin-offs while it's cool if you
like the follow up shows we don't think
they quite match the 1960s original
until scooby-doo mystery Incorporated
hit our screens it was in 2010 that
Warner Brothers announced the new show
it told the story of how they got
together and started solving mysteries
what was so invigorating about the new
show was that it simultaneously took the
show back to its root and into new
places acknowledging that a franchise
that started more than 40 years ago
would have fans all ages it tipped its
hat to a range of pop-culture references
viewers would have spotted nods to other
beloved shows like Wacky Races and the
1960s Batman they would have also seen
homage 'as to legendary rock acts like
The Velvet Underground and the Ramones -
and they would have got away with it if
it wasn't for you pesky kids
but while we'd love the original Scooby
Doo we think that scooby-doo mystery
Incorporated is even better than the
original two extreme Ghostbusters most
of the show's we are
today are reboots of the original
cartoons in some cases they are the
first time the classic show has been
updated for a new audience in others
they are the best in a pretty long line
of remakes but this next one is a little
bit different
you see back in the 1980s it wasn't
uncommon for a live-action movie to turn
into a smash hit kids cartoon and the
biggest in this sub-genre was the Real
Ghostbusters taking the 1984 classic
movie it animated the main characters
made Slimer an icon and kept Ray Parker
jr.
stone-cold legendary theme tune for a
lot of the kids born in the 80s Peter
Venkman Egon Spengler ray Stantz
and winston zeddemore were cartoons
before they were flesh and blood but
everything changes and in 1997 there was
a new generation of ghostbusters for
fans to enjoy Egon stayed and served as
a mentor for Kylie Eduardo Garrett and
Roland's joining them were original
Ghostbusters secretary Jeanine and of
course Slimer the program had a grittier
more streetwise animation style this was
matched by a zeitgeist II grunge punk
version of the classic theme tune the
show dealt with big topics tackling
racism prejudice and diversity the shock
to the system it provided paved the way
for the 2016 all-female movie remake
we're still fans of the Real
Ghostbusters but extreme Ghostbusters is
we think and under lists classic one the
Powerpuff Girls when it comes to
rebooting a much-loved classic series
timing can be everything if you do it
too soon people will shrug their
shoulders and wonder why you've done it
if you leave it too long it makes your
job harder fans who love taking the show
to their hearts and won't countenance
the idea of remaking it so we think the
gap between the original Powerpuff Girls
and its reboot 14 years is perfect
there's enough of a break for people to
get nostalgic but it's not too long that
viewers ideas of what a show is get
fixed for kids growing up around the
turn of the millennium the stories of
Blossom Bubbles and Buttercup were
thrilling and iconic when the Cartoon
Network announced it was rebooting the
show in 2016 lots of us were really
excited not only were the Powerpuff
Girls back they were better than ever
they still had their superpowers
bestowed on them by professor utonium
still
Chemical X on them while in the lab but
the shows were now more character-driven
and there was even just a dash of social
commentary with the addition of the
fourth Powerpuff Girl Bliss the show had
25% more so we think the new Powerpuff
Girls is even better than the original
but what do you think what's your
favorite cartoon reboot and which
classic cartoon would you like to see
rebooted tell us in the comments that
wraps up our 5 cartoon reboots that are
way better than the original if you
liked it check out 10 cartoons that look
different in other countries thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to the things
[Music]